do you plan on getting into me with him
a hundred percent but he's waiting to
see just like how the relationship goes
we're gonna go with the flow awkward
well thankfully she has honest friends
it is awkward it is awkward when it
comes to uzman kim is saying
but the problem is that he does not feel
how she feels
kim's about to travel to africa to meet
usmen and he booked them separate rooms
do i like it not really not really but
we're going to talk about it plus
these are the little blue pills we'll
get into how gino is preparing to meet
his younger hot girlfriend jasmine and
why this relationship has me so confused
jasmine likes to know every time i go
out
uh from my home
yeah
let's get started
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
season five of before the 90 days is
here in the casting team at tlc
they've done it again first things first
meet kimberly my best friends would
describe me as maybe a little bit crazy
just a little bit she's 50 years old
from san diego she has a grown son
you're always going to be my baby you
know that right
and she also takes care of her mom she
has rheumatoid arthritis in her hips and
it's caused her to to not be mobile so i
pretty much do everything for her
but
i think there is one important thing to
note
kim
is also a super fan
on this wall and everything is my
michael jackson collection when she
becomes a fan of someone and it was
actually one that he wore she gets
passionate about it it's the fedora and
the glove from when he did billie jean
and then i call him my mikey so it's my
mikey and my handwriting as you can see
she has no shame in professing her love
for michael jackson to the world
now that's a ride or die i feel like i
own a piece of him and oh yeah if you're
wondering according to kim that fedora
is worth about eight to nine thousand
dollars
[Laughter]
tells you
ride or die
and yes she's doing the moonwalk my fan
because kimberly came to you as my fan i
think all of this might give us some
context on why she goes so hard for
oozman who's about 18 years younger than
her i am listening to usman umar aka
soulja boy
[Music]
from nigeria kim opened up about how she
met uzman on social media after she
messaged him and told him she was a fan
he messaged me back and i was like oh my
god he messaged me like what is this and
we ended up talking for like three hours
for those of you who aren't aware which
i'm sure most of you are oozman appeared
on last seasons before the 90 days with
his ex lisa who just so happens to also
be a more mature
white american woman actually
i don't think a relationship somebody
would have typed but
i can't say that i actually don't have
time i just
my type is somebody who is going to give
me peace from the beginning he was
accused of using her to get a green card
which he denies
i am not
scamming anybody so considering those
things on top of his number one goal
my goal is to be the number one artist
or among the number of top top artists
in the world i'm worried for kim i swear
i have never been so happy he has
completely changed my life i get it she
wants a reason to be happy and excited
and he's giving that to her
but it's clearly looking like a setup
for heartbreak
what's not clicking what's not clicking
i feel so much emotion when i talk about
him he just makes me so happy and i
haven't been
happy with a man in so long he makes me
feel so loved side note in this moment
they aren't actually together the
producer called her out you know we're
dating and we're going to see what
happens and see how much further we're
going to carry this so
are you guys ready
um
i i consider us dating um
i don't know what he considers it
right now usman calls me his potential
girlfriend potential girlfriend we are
grown what is this grade school
right now usman calls me his potential
girlfriend only because of the
experiences with his ex-wife
if that's what she wants to believe
okay
speaking of exes when it comes to kim's
past relationship she revealed that her
ex-husband the father of her son cheated
on her with a number of women after they
were together for 28 years
having been so loyal to somebody that
didn't reciprocate that to me was a very
hurtful thing
and it's pretty much been years of
non-stop bad luck ever since and now
she's putting her hope in good old use
men it is time for us to meet in person
after getting to know each other for a
year online and over the phone usman has
invited kim to meet him in tanzania yes
for a music video shoot for one of his
songs she leaves in a couple of days in
her mission
to prove to usmen she is not lisa
i'm not her and i'm a thousand times
better than her and i'm doing this
because i'm following my heart and he
knows that i'm a hundred percent loyal
i'm a hundred percent i'm not crazy at
the end of the day it's a relationship
for me and it's my happiness as well as
his and i know that i can make him happy
i know that but i'm i'm fearful of my
heart being broken you and the rest of
us
hey i hope uzman shocks us all
because this lady could be devastated
listen to what her mom said what if they
get over there
and there's no chemistry
that's gonna kill her
it's gonna kill her those are some
powerful words i tried to tell oozman
this but scamming isn't just about using
someone for money or a green card at the
core of it it's taking advantage of a
vulnerable person to get whatever it is
you're trying to gain
in this case it can be as simple as
trying to gain attention i love being on
tv this is what i've been doing since
from childhood yeah he might like being
on tv but i don't think kim is just in
it for tv time
she clearly likes him a lot she's about
to leave her mom for him
even though a family friend is going to
be looking after my mom while i'm gone
it's very very nerve-wracking for me
this trip will be the longest i've been
away from her since i've became her
caregiver like i said i hope he shocks
us all
[Music]
in the meantime before
[Music]
and they didn't waste any time asking
her if she plans to get intimate
do you plan on getting with him
a hundred percent but he's waiting to
see just like how the relationship goes
we're to go with the flow awkward it is
awkward
i mean that's why you decided on two
separate rooms
[Music]
i got my room he got his room usman has
told me that he would feel more
comfortable if he was in a separate room
you know until we determine like what
our relationship is
do i like it not really not really
because i don't want to feel like i'm
there by myself but um i guarantee i
will bet you too many that by the end of
the trip he will be in my room
y'all better start throwing out numbers
i'm joking but kim
she wants to see this a certain way
and nothing is going to change that
not even reality
it's kind of like out there because
guzman started off as like um saying
what's up to a fan and turned into kim
head over heels right
she just freely gave her heart away
all right let's move on to gino i am 51
years young and i live in kent michigan
preparing for his trip to go meet 34
year old jasmine who lives in panama for
the first time
and oh yeah
get used to geno wearing his hat he said
he's never taking it off i prefer how i
look with the hannah
which just makes you want to see his
head even more but
okay earlier this year i decided to look
internationally on a dating site for
love because i wasn't having much luck
locally
and that's how i made my girlfriend
jasmine
the love of my life and to be honest
she's out of my league
but
you know we've been talking for nine
months and she's like i think my my soul
mate and i haven't even met her yet
that is 90 days for you as gina was
gearing up for his love mission he
revealed that he went through the k1
visa process once before
with his brazilian ex-wife who he was
with for seven years
i worked in brazil for six months as an
engineer
we met around that time he also revealed
that it's been a long time since he's
been intimate with a woman and he's
nervous because jasmine has a ton of
sexual energy
that's why he got the blue pills
these are the little blue pills it can
make you last longer
where did you get those
online
you better be careful i've already tried
trialled these
so i know they work
like wow man i mean this stuff works
it's good
besides that when gino gets to panama
his plan is to propose to jasmine
which has his family worried
you going there and only
being with her three weeks
and you want to put a ring on it
[Music]
and you want to put a ring on it another
thing that's concerning is gina lost his
job during the pandemic
yet he's been giving jasmine money out
of his savings account for cosmetic
procedures
i've helped for things such as you know
doing her lips or maybe her eyebrows
or
um maybe facial treatment
um possibly her hair or her teeth
um
yeah i've helped her out with those
things i know i know sounds like an
obvious scam right
but i will say after watching this first
episode
i'm a bit confused about jasmine's
intentions
here's why
hi baby
i just ordered some food and i'm gonna
go pick it up
has these moments where she gets
extremely jealous over gino i don't know
if she's joking or not but
she says
evidence reports
so usually when i go out i'll send her a
screenshot to check in with her because
she wants to know where i'm at at all
times he's smiling but that is scary
uh the person serving my food
how you doing
okay
and what's your first name i'm brittany
brittany okay
yeah it's nice meeting you all right
baby i'm gonna go back home
my question is is she making herself
jealous by faking it so much that she
actually becomes serious you were just
or
is she jealous because she's really into
him
because you know it was my first time in
the restaurant
what do you think is going on here i'm
confused i guess you can scam someone
and get jealous because you don't want
anyone else getting the perks
gino's uncle and his girlfriend thinks
she could be setting him up it's just
strange what if they kidnap him or
something and yeah what if you know and
they take his card and all his money he
wakes up in a hotel room with a roofie
his money's gone everything's gone
goodbye nice girl oh yo
i know you're upset about it a little
bit but you don't have to yell it's just
the way i feel either way her jealousy
is a red flag and geno should probably
run but
i think he's set on using those blue
pills
like wow man i mean this stuff works
it's good
ass's uncle was dropping him off at the
airport to finally go meet jasmine he
got really emotional which kind of made
me feel for gino you know i'm
just uh thinking about a lot of things
that could happen to him
thank you so much yeah that's no problem
a little emotional about leaving him
his dad just passed away recently last
christmas
so i'm uncle dad you know
that's my baby man he's my
he's been my buddy since he's been
running around in diapers you know
and i worry about him i really do oh
gina was love
well next week he lands in panama and
hopefully he has those blue pills ready
because jasmine is ready to get it in
really oh my god
oh i can already tell this season is
going to be something else how did you
feel about the first episode let me know
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
you